des tests antigénique accessible à tous
au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
une deuxième opération de dépistage
massive sur deux jours les mardi 1er et
mercredi 2 décembre pour augmenter la
sécurité sanitaire
c'est de casser la chaîne de propagation
des quelqu'un sait si l'aïe ne se
comporte plus la même façon il réduit
ses contacts sociaux
je suivais la phase test qu'aux vide
j'ai reçu un message de sur facebook
parce que je connais juste le site est
ce que y
donc j'ai inscrit ce dr libre où l
opération d'une nouvelle organisation
les tests sont disponibles gratuitement
et sans ordonnance les personnes
volontaires se font tester une à une et
sont ensuite dirigé vers une salle
d'attentes
les résultats sont disponibles en 15
minutes pour fluidifier le passage les
rendez vous sont à prendre via la
plateforme d'octo libre c'est très sain
moi j'ai été informée par ma commune
j'ai eu un lien et puis comme je n'avais
jamais été inscrite sur dr il a fallu
que je crée mon compte et ensuite les
questions sont posées ont rempli et puis
on a immédiatement la validation sur le
téléphone une répétition du futur
vaccinodromes qui se tiendra au
vélodrome
objectif améliorer encore l'organisation
et être fin prêt à partir de janvier
pour de potentiels vaccin ça nous permet
de préparer l'opération
quand même forte de janvier je pense
c'est entre janvier et février on aura
certainement peut avoir près de cent
mille personnes qu'il faudra vacciner en
ironie son très rapide avec des médecins
des pharmaciens donc la meilleure
condition sanitaire une organisation
la plus impeccable possible lors de la
première opération en septembre dernier
près de 2000 personnes se sont fait
tester